hello and welcome to the introductory
video
of the aws sysops administrator
associate level course
offered by simplylearn in this video
you will get to know some of the
interesting facts about aws
get a brief overview about the course
and know how the certification
can help your career amazon web services
provides a highly reliable scalable
low-cost
infrastructure platform in the cloud
that powers
hundreds of thousands of businesses in
190 countries
around the world the worldwide cloud
computing market
grew 28 to 110 billion dollars in
revenues in 2015.
in the first quarter of 2016 amazon web
services or
aws revenue was up by 58
the certification holder takes home an
average salary
of eight 125 seventy one dollars
up from one hundred fourteen thousand
nine hundred thirty five dollars last
year
according to forbes there are over 18
million jobs in the field of cloud
computing globally
aws sysops administrator associate
is the perfect certification to prove
your technical expertise in deploying
managing and operating scalable highly
available
and fault-tolerant systems on aws
platform
you'll enhance your existing knowledge
of aws
so you can select the appropriate
products and tools
to leverage aws in the most efficient
and cost effective way you'll learn how
to implement and control the flow of
data
to and from aws and also be able to
estimate aws usage costs
and identify operational cost control
mechanisms
with the certification you will be an
asset to any organization helping it to
leverage the benefits of best practices
around
advanced cloud-based solutions and
migrate on-premises
applications to aws simply learns
aws sysops administrator associate level
course
will help you understand the key
concepts required to prepare for the
certification exam
before diving into the course details
let us get a glimpse of
all the interesting ways you get to
learn about aws
delve into the various aws services
work with aws management console
learn the cli commands validate your
knowledge
the practice assignments and the three
live projects
are included especially for you to gain
hands-on experience
with aws management console and the cli
to become a domain expert in building
deploying and managing systems in aws
this course comprises 24 hours of
instructor-led training
15 hours of e-learning and three hours
of demonstrations
to understand technical details
associated with data management
networking security and more you will
also be provided with three question
sets
totaling 180 questions to validate the
depth of your knowledge
learning path this certification also
serves as a prerequisite for the aws
devops engineer professional exam
whether you are looking to future-proof
your career or enhance your know-how
about the leading cloud provider in the
global market
becoming an aws sysops administrator
associate
will put you well on your way to
achieving your career goals
you should ideally be an i.t
professional with experience in both
traditional i.t
infrastructure and the aws platform
you should have experience in everyday
operations of a system administrator
which include deployment of the it
systems backups
os management and have some experience
with the aws platform
you can reach out to the teaching
assistant support staff
anytime during the course and for
assistance with projects
you can submit your queries at help and
support on our website
or get connected with our staff using
simplytalk
and live chat options this concludes the
course introduction
and we hope you are all geared up to
begin the aws
sysops administrator associate level
course
let's get started with the first lesson
monitoring and metrics
happy learning